so when you think about
what is money right that's kind of the
first question people really kind of go
down the rabbit hole on
and ultimately today it's a belief
system
right and you may believe that one
currency has more value over another
because it's backed by a certain
military or a certain government has
a monetary policy that you believe in or
don't believe in
but ultimately it's a belief system that
there's nothing backing this
uh other than a government asks you to
pay your taxes in it
right and they can have a monopoly on
violence uh in terms they can put you in
jail if you don't pay your taxes
they can go to other countries and they
can invade and do all this stuff
it wasn't always like that right it was
historically
a layer one technology was gold and so
gold was
a fantastic store of value you knew that
if you held gold it wasn't going to be
inflated away it was sound money it was
outside the system and no one could
create more of it
the reason why that's important is
because that optimization for store of
value served as the bedrock
of the entire stack of uh money
for 5 000 years and so the problem with
that though again trade-off between
store of value is it was really hard to
transact with
right if i came in here and i and you
said hey i want a couple of ounces of
gold and i had a whole bar i'd have to
literally shave off the ounces of gold
uh it's heavy to carry around if you
said to me hey
you're in one city mail it to me it's
really expensive you know there's all
these issues with it
and so ultimately what people said was
well let's create a second layer
on top of that gold in order to make it
easier to transact and so we created
paper claims on the gold so hey don't
carry around the gold in your pocket
anymore
put it in a vault or a bank they're
going to issue a paper claim
now you and i can trade these paper
claims around and at any point if you
want the gold you just show up and you
say hey give me you know three ounces of
gold or two bars or whatever
and so that actually made the store a
value it was
allowed that to be the anchor and kind
of the most important part the security
of
your purchasing power but now it became
easier to transact and then eventually
we built layers even on top of that so
everything from electronic money
kind of electronic q-sips all the way to
credit and other systems on top of that
gold
1971 comes around and obviously we d-peg
from that
gold right it was a temporary measure at
the time we ended up not going back to
it
and so what she moved or transitioned
from was sound money which was outside
the system no one could create more
to now the government had full control
they could create as much as they wanted
to
they tried to be responsible and
disciplined but obviously hard to do
sometimes we've been really good at it
sometimes we've been less good at it and
you go around the world and some
countries have absolutely
sucked at it and some have been good at
it
you